hello friends welcome to our
youtube-channel simpler IV sciences we
are here with the mission to spread Agri
Sciences in a simplified manner among
farmers students and those personals who
are interested in farming and we will
begin our ride from the berries focusing
on how agricultural cultivation
practices changed so far in our country
India with the hope that it will benefit
you in many ways so let's start this
video and watch it till the end to learn
the impact of Agriculture and spread the
knowledge as much as possible among us
in the agricultural cultivation history
traces back to Indus Valley Civilisation
and it was also evidence to be found in
some places of southern India cereals
shrubs fibers were domesticated crop and
dog goat shape when domesticated animals
to begin with conventional point
technique mostly used in farming for
cultivation practices in Vedic
literature attic Veda describing about
plumbing
following irrigation in the field for
cultivation of fruits and vegetables are
some proven facts in form of written
records of agriculture in India evidence
suggests that rice and cotton were
cultivated since Indus Valley day it was
also reported that some archaeologists
believed that rice was cultivated as
domesticated crop near the ganges river
banks since 6th millennium before Christ
and other crops such as barley oats
wheat lentil chickpea pulses millets
cotton and cocoa butter sheis fruits
were also grown in different parts of
India plying patterns were taken from
the Bronze Age and this technique was
involved being drawn by two oxen fastin
to the wooden cross base attached to the
plough to pull together traditional
agricultural implements used mostly at
the time made of bronze namely
sickle 101 which are still used by many
farmers now
bamboo sieves Witter and X more than
2,000 years ago Indian farmers begin
growing many spices and sugarcane crop
and spreading of sugarcane cultivation
took place when Macedonian soldiers
carried Reed's
or tall grasses which were honey bearing
on their return journey and process to
produce these sugar crystals were
invented by the period 500 this now as
clear as it is that agriculture is the
backbone of our country's economy and
depending on the three factors such as
climate technological development and
social culture practices cultivation
methods also changed quite significantly
now farming at present can be of
subsistence and commercial depth under
subsistence type shifting cultivation
which is also known as slash-and-burn is
still practiced by many farmers to grow
cereals and other food crops it is a
system which involves shifting from one
plot to another by abandoning the former
after exhausting it and let it revert
its natural vegetation the purpose of
such kind is to allow natural
replenishment of soil fertility
following natural processes
now this farming practice is known with
different names in various regions of
the country and in other countries as
well
for example zooming in northeastern
states deeper inside this grid district
and under Magna cover Island they were
in multiple dish odo in anther British
and in other countries like Mexico and
Central America it is known as milpa
Roca in Brazil and another in Indonesia
even today some primitive tools like how
thou sticks community Labor's on wage
basis are used in agricultural practices
on small batch of plants although such
farming is entirely dependent on monsoon
season soil fertility and other
environmental conditions that favor crop
growth
India has three cropping seasons namely
the behave and Zayn and crops are sown
accordingly in different time of the
year
now Rabi crops such as wheat barley
chickpea peas mustard
they are sown in winter from October to
November and harvested in summer from
March to eppley and they are predominant
in Indian states like Punjab Haryana
Himachal Pradesh with the Pradesh Jammu
and Kashmir no.3 Condor on the other
hand Karif crops like rice millet maize
green drum like them and so on
are sown with onset of monsoon and
harvested in September to October they
are predominantly cultivated in states
like Odisha Rajasthan Andhra Pradesh
Telangana Maharashtra Tamina with
spangled and Kerala the third seasons a
crops like cucumber watermelon musk
melon pumpkin and bitter gourd are sown
in between Ravi and curry
during summer for instance in February
to march or March to July now Indian
villages witnessed tremendous
transformation of Agriculture from
self-sufficient production to commercial
production with extensive services
through commercial farming commercial
output provided by agricultural
practices involved mostly about raising
crops in large scales or estates and
shipping of the produce to other
countries for monetization thinly
populated states like Tamil Nadu Punjab
Haryana Gujarat
have adapted the commercial farming
system for plantation already and main
crops grown for the purpose are with
maize cotton and sugar cane so
commercial farming is of two types
namely intensive commercial farming
which requires large amounts of capital
or labor with relatively smaller areas
of land and another is a
tensive commercial farming which
requires investment of small amounts of
capital and labor with relatively large
areas of land farmers of India still
have skeptical views when it comes to
adapting new scientific technologies to
grow their crop in present situation
they have grown a mixed attitude towards
farming technologies which is evidenced
by growing of new plant varieties
alongside 30 to 50 year old varieties
adjacent to the field area while owning
mobile phones to check regularly about
crop prices but fail to pay attention to
the necessary information about best
methods to grow their crop for higher
yield here we can possibly interpret the
reluctance of adopting new technology
pointing at first that less emphasis
have been given to the communication of
science to the farmers second deformed
ways to promote the adoption of new
technology another barrier is dead
sometimes farmers interest does not meet
i - i with scientists or technical
person soil test results for which we
see varied range of prices in case of
macro and micro nutrients unfortunately
in most parts of the country covering
mostly the rural areas the poor still
indicate that approximately 45% and 26%
women and men respectively are
illiterate and unaware of even the basic
economics all the government took step
to form fine policy tool in terms of
incentives or subsidies to promote new
agricultural technologies in India for
example higher yield seed varieties
advanced instruments and developed
machineries irrespective of the attempt
it is associated with pros and cons as
companies draw some unnecessary
additional features to the product for
profit maximization here in view of this
all effective and more simplified
scientific communication to the farmers
and tweaking policies at certain level
good perhaps reflects some different
picture on the overall obstacles the
strategies however to increase the crop
yield and spread of Agriculture
education could boost of the economic
growth of the country in an exponential
manner the new strategies if adopted may
change the scenario for example use of
improved seed varieties stronghold on
land ownership crop rotation irrigation
methods such as drip irrigation and
sprinkler irrigation and appropriate use
of farm machinery x' improve package and
practices protective measures for
pathogen and insect attacks to make
farming profitable increase in minimum
support prices may 8 to 9 to 5 percent
cost Rotem now this perhaps will trigger
the indian farmers to invest more in
agriculture small holder farmers with
their entrepreneurial strategies could
be encouraged to invest in their farms
and turn their image around for
agricultural growth status of the
country as they own more than 80 percent
of the total farming land and 50% of
livestock in India but due to low
produce low productivity and market
pricing status they do not receive what
is expected and thus discouraging fact
to invest in Fernie however a market
with price transparency new land leasing
laws and investments in life stocks
could encourage the smallholder farmers
to invest with enthusiasm so presently
we see there is a wave of organic food
consumption to build a better health
thus sustainable farming movement can
set the opportunity for a bright future
of agricultural cultivation all the
organic movement started long back in
1921 and the pioneering work promulgated
by Albert Howard who is known as a
father of organic farming and his wife
Gabrielle
Howard when in early 1900 scientists who
are seeking for solution for the side
effects of the toxic chemicals entering
the food supply and certainly declining
the overall natural soil fertility but
current era people have already realized
another aware about how consumption of
junk foods causing greater ill effects
on their health and thus causing
lifestyle diseases
especially who are residing in the urban
cities general awareness from national
and international exposure helping
people to take steps avoid such
lifestyle diseases by switching into
organ in deaths so certified organic
foods ensuring growth of organic market
under the influence of scrutiny and
regulations since past few years organic
farming has witnessed a tremendous
development almost in every crop type
due to the general awareness of the
end-users for healthy foods and also
environmental safety it is reported
according to w-h-o the organic food
market is around 37 billion dollars at
present already so it is to be believed
that health-conscious end-users will
promote the growth of organic
agriculture sector in future India so
here we hope that you have enjoyed this
video and the informations as we had
making it and if you did be sure to give
it a thumbs up and subscribe to our
channel if you found it helpful you can
share it with your friends and family
who are interested to learn about
agriculture and find value in it too and
please do leave a comment below we'd
love to hear from you we are open for
suggestions and share any topics you
want us to cover we will see you with
our next video thank